in this Browns video we introduced seven
ways to learn a new language drown
yourself to swimming leave the comfort
of your home and go to the place where
they speak nothing but the language that
you want to learn then live there for
the next six to twelve months it might
be painful and lonely at times but you
will surely learn how to speak the
language and enjoy some memorable
experiences immersion perhaps easier and
also effective is immersion or when you
learn a new language for exposure and
context so for example if you are
learning Italian do so in a pizzeria
you can try to read the menu or maybe
even go as far as order in Italian
antipasti pizza tano or gelato anybody
mnemonics mnemonics is a method to learn
new vocabulary by creating an
association that makes it easy to
remember for example let's say you want
to remember the French word choux which
means cabbage in English choux is
pronounced like shoo in English so you
could imagine putting cabbages on your
feet instead of shoes then when you need
to remember cabbage your brain will
think cabbage shoes shoe scriptorium
scriptorium is an exercise in writing
students write the language while
simultaneously speaking it out loud
before you write a sentence you should
first read it out loud second say each
word aloud again as you write it and
third read the sentence aloud again
after you have written it the purpose of
this exercise is to force yourself to
slow down and pay attention to detail
and then review unknown words and
refresh your grammar shadowing
shadowing is used to learn vocabulary
you listen to new words through
headphones and try to repeat to shadow
them out loud as quickly as you can
inventor Alexander AR gales who speaks
50 languages suggests that you do it
while walking swiftly to maximize
alertness and blood flow tech and apps
if you want to learn a new language but
you don't have anybody who can help
check out what's available online
duolingo for example teaches many
languages entirely for free it's fun and
effective as they make you practice
reading writing listening and speaking
Quizlet is a great tool to study
vocabulary it allows you to explore
audio-supported flashcards so you can
learn new words and get the
pronunciation right
get a study buddy if you are not into
technology and would rather learn with
others do what popular youtuber Timothy
doner aka polyglot Powell recommends
connect with people from around the
world to teach and learn from each other
via Skype it's one of the things that
work for him and he already speaks 20
languages and he's not even 18 thanks
for watching
also check out other sprouts learning
techniques as they can compliment the
methods explained in this video please
use the comments below to give us
feedback or tell us which of the
techniques is your favorite if any
you